this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you well this is really a pleasure
for me to be here because I son I know
so many of you and there's gonna be a
lot of really fun science to cover over
the next day and I've had a great
morning already I love it that you guys
have your seminars at noon and not at 4
o'clock which is what Indiana University
does by 4 o'clock the audience is asleep
and the speaker is following asleep so
right by noon I think this is a great
schedule so my talk today is on these
extracellular vesicles those of you that
know my history know that this is not my
expertise or my background so this was a
new direction for my lab but that's part
of why I'm having so much fun with it
because I'm having to learn a lot of new
biology to understand what we've
uncovered and also the excitement of
going into it really is a new field in
plant biology so I hope to share some of
that excitement with you all today so
the the reason we got into this project
is all stems from this VM image right
here so zoom in just a little bit this
is a am image that we took trying to
follow up on a result from a japanese
group that was investigating the
question of how do plant cells die when
you activate a defense response the
classic defense response I think most of
you probably know is called the
hypersensitive resistance response it's
marked by rapid breakdown of cell
membranes and cell death and this
Japanese group had published a paper
suggesting that the key event was fusion
of the vacuolar membrane which in this
image this these are two Arab adopts as
musical cells that have been infected
with an Abrial and strain of Pseudomonas
and this thin layer here is the
cytoplasm and then that's cell wall this
is extra cellular space and we were
really interested in this vacuolar
membrane adjacent to the plasma membrane
and we were looking for fusion events
because that's what had been reported in
this paper and so we used
algae called focused ion beam scanning
electron microscopy to take literally
300 serial sections through an
Arabidopsis leaf looking to see if we
could find any of these fusion events
that had been supported we couldn't we
did not find any of these fusion events
but we did find were these things which
were really interesting structures to me
I didn't really they weren't in the
textbooks that I had been brought up on
and so I showed these images to a plant
cell colleague of mine at IU Sid Shaw
who's really a great cell biologist say
it had been an undergraduate with Andrew
Staley at University of Colorado Boulder
it was one of the people who was on my
committee as a graduate student and Sid
knew these as para mural bodies and so
see you zoom in on those things they're
really interesting because the plasma
membrane is broken down underneath them
and so the general thought from e/m
images of these so-called pyramidal
bodies is that they are actually dumping
vesicles
into the extracellular space so here's
cell wall here this is the vacuole or
membrane this is the plasma membrane and
the cytoplasm is this thin little shell
right here
but these para mural bodies are pretty
large structures relative to the width
of the cytoplasm and so that obviously
takes some effort to make that kind of
structure and if you look at the thing
in three dimensions what you can do with
this focused ion beam SEM this is what
it looks like so you have these you know
sir this is what it would look like if
you're swimming around in the vacuole
looking out at the vacuole or membrane
so these things you know sticking to
that vacuolar space and so these seem to
be more abundant and leaves that we had
treated with Pseudomonas compared to
leaves that weren't they seemed like
they might be associated with the
defense response and now given this word
para mural body I could search the
literature to see whether anybody else
had reported these and described these
and I found out they
well documented in the 1970s in the
context of electron micrographs of
powdery mildew barley interactions and
these we go back to this these sorts of
structures you see collecting around
penetration sites and I'll show you some
more images of that in a moment but that
godess excited that we're on to some
defense response that had been kind of
overlooked in the context especially of
bacterial interactions so I put one
graduate student on it to start working
on it it's kind of a high-risk project
to see we can learn more about these
vesicles and in particularly challenged
him to see we could purify them and
we'll come back to that but I said I was
excited about this so I decided I wanted
to learn more about the electron
microscopy and to do that I went to
University of Colorado Boulder to see
Andrew Stalin get his wisdom he's
retired at this point but he was still
coming into his office every day and at
Universe Colorado Boulder they have at
the Center for 3d electron microscopy
and they also have expertise and high
pressure freezing which is a way to
really preserve the integrity of
membranes during fixing cells of any
type but especially plant cells so this
image here is one that I took on
sabbatical it's the only data that I
generated in this whole talk but I'm
proud of this so I talk about that and
what you see here is again so long this
is a chloroplast that starch granules
this is the cytoplasm but notice these
vesicles here they're trapped between
the cell wall and the plasma membrane
and it turned out I had no trouble
finding these sorts of images it's
common to see vesicles stuck between the
plasma membrane and the cell wall and
they don't even have to be infected
plants so this seems to be something
that's happening all the time and
musical cells at least and so this
really made me think that it might be
possible that to purify these things
from the aprile class from the
extracellular space and that's what we
basically set out to do
but while in bold and yeah in bolder
talking to Andrew and you know showing
them these this image and and this this
image Andrew got excited about that and
said well those look like llamas ohms to
me and that was another word that I
didn't know I searched PubMed for llamas
ohm it wasn't even in there but it was
an Andrews brain and he went to his file
cabinet and pulled out this paper from
1967 you know Andrews office has this
wall of file cabinets and he knew right
where in the file cabinet this paper was
from 1967 which was just blew me away
but what this was is a carrot cell
culture and here's this beautiful um
images of what they labeled a multi
vesicular body opening up against the
cell wall and so it looked like these
vesicles were being now outside the
plant cell and again here these multi
particular body and then also in the
same paper there's this image and with
this shows in particularly is lots of
vesicles now in the extracellular space
and again and here's another multi
particular body that seems to be
emptying as vesicles out between the
plasma membrane and the cell wall and
here's kind of junction of three cells
and getting lots of vesicles so we've
literally known that plant cells produce
extracellular vesicles for over 50 years
but they've just been sort of
observations in e/m nobody's really
figured out what their role was and this
is what got me excited to try to figure
out you know what are these things doing
so there there have been of course
follow-up analyses of fungal plant
interactions where people are doing
eeehm and this paper here from 2006 so
now only 12 years ago had some beautiful
images this is from Ralph oklahomans lab
in Germany if you know any of else work
he works mostly on barley powdery
mildews interactions what is shown here
is a fungus penetrating through the
plant cell wall and this is
the epidermal cell and the plants
producing what's called a cell wall
opposition sometimes they're also called
papillae and and this is a buildup of
membranous material kalos and other
compounds that people think of as a
physical barrier to penetration by the
fungus and so this is just kind of a
cartoon drawing of it and what you can
see in this manuscript is or paper is
these param your bodies that are full of
vesicles that seem to be dumping their
contents into the cell wall opposition
again you see it here too but these are
complex membranous structures and so
again you know why what are they doing
and then this is now a similar image but
taken by a new collaborator of mine
Richard O'Connell who has a lab in ret
in France and he does beautiful high
pressure on eemm work and and this I
think are fantastic images and and what
is shown here again is plant cell fungal
cell vesicle here between the plasma
membrane and and fungal wall in this
case importantly the fungus is this is
called talk Turkey I'm going to make on
a beam leaf the fungus also is producing
extracellular vesicles and that's what's
shown here so this is fungal cytoplasm
plasma membrane and these vesicles again
some more here and this is similar that
previous image from barley but now this
is on a beam leaf this is the papilla or
cell wall that position fungus trying to
penetrate and again lots of vesicles
being produced right here so there's
certainly lots of AM data then and then
the last one am in this series I'm going
to show you is this is I'm not taking in
my lab by my graduate student Brian
router this is a cross-section through a
historian powdery mildew infecting in
Arabidopsis leaves so this is an
epidermal cell and Arabidopsis this is a
lobe of the powdery mildew fungal
historian so lots of mitochondria here
this is extra historial matrix here so
the space between the plant cell which
is over here
and the fungal cell and what I want you
to note here is this darkly staining
membranous material and what this looks
like to me is micro villi on an
intestine so you've just hugely expanded
the membrane surface area at this
feeding site for the fungus so and this
is this is a compatible interaction that
the fungus is growing happily here and
so I interpret this as the fungus
inducing a massive outgrowth of the
plasma membrane of the host cell to
enhance transport of materials from the
host cell into the fungus but when you
look at this these sort of micro villi
type structure you can imagine that you
could easily pinch off vesicles directly
from the plasma membrane to make
extracellular vesicles so I think there
may be two independent ways to make
extracellular vesicles here one is
direct pinching off a plasma membrane
and the other is through this multi
vesicular body pair mural body pathway
that we was just showing so beyond the
e/m there's quite a bit of other
evidence before our work to suggest that
extracellular vesicles are important in
the defense response and this comes from
a series of papers so this is from hans
floral Christensen's lab now started to
collaborate with where they were using
fluorescently look tagged GT piezas that
are associated with multi particular
bodies and localizing them to sites of
fungal penetration so again this was
powdery mildew it was this work and they
showed that these MB bees that are
tagged with the gtp as marker accumulate
at the penetration sites and seemed to
be fusing with the plasma membrane work
that preceded that but is directly
related showed that syntax ins required
these same gtp aces to function in the
context of penetration resistance and so
this was work being done in both barley
and Arabidopsis where Paul's lab was
looking for a rabid office mutants that
became more susceptible to a barley
strain
of powdery mildew so normally that
barley strain can't even penetrate an
Arabidopsis epidermal cell and in these
mutants which they called penetration
mutants they found that the barley
powdery mildew could get further and
actually form a historian and so the one
of the mutants was a syntaxin and and
that's going to be a large player later
in the story here so that syntaxin they
showed in 2009 in a really seminal paper
that that syntax and accumulated in this
pillar matrix and the reason that was
important is that some toxins are
proteins that mediate membrane membrane
fusion so they are involved in mediating
the fusion of vesicles with the plasma
membrane normally they're considered
cytoplasmic proteins but anchored to
membranes by a c terminal signal and the
fact that they were getting outside the
cell was puzzling because they're not
normally secreted through a standard
secretory pathway they don't have a
signal peptide but yet they were showing
that these proteins were accumulating in
this matrix here and they even suggested
in this 2009 paper that perhaps they're
being secreted via extracellular
vesicles and they used the term exosome
which is common term used in the
mammalian field or extracellular
vesicles and so it was really this paper
that got us really focused on this idea
of figuring out if the exosomes are
important in defense okay so the kind of
questions raised by this that we wanted
to answer is what do these vesicles
contain how are they produced and what
triggers their release because we
already had evidence that there was some
sort of regulation of it obviously the
fungal penetration site was a place of
focus for a release and then obviously
what is it they do and so this is what
we embarked on trying to answer and
really all the work that I'm going to
present from here on out is from a
single graduate student Brian Rutter and
he has discovered all sorts of really
interesting things about these vesicles
so if before I jump into all that data
let me just review what's going on in
the mammalian world because there's a
lot of excitement a million world about
extracellular vesicles and so this comes
a 2013 review and the the main
excitement in the in the mammalian world
is that these vesicles contain small
RNAs so what's being shown here is small
RNAs being packaged into what are called
intraluminal vesicles in these multi
particular bodies or multi vesicular
endosomes these them fusing with the
plasma membrane releasing their vesicles
and then the vesicles being taken up by
mechanism that's not clear yet into host
cells those rnas get released and they
affect gene expression in the host cell
and so this is a really hot topic in the
mammalian world now because it turns out
there's all sorts of diseases that seem
to be mediated in part by extracellular
vesicles and in particular cancer cancer
cells release vesicles with a different
content of small RNAs compared to a
healthy cell and it seems to be
functionally important and I'll go
through some of the literature on that
shortly so this is what I just told you
so we'll skip through that so the
history of exosomes
in the mammalian world kind of dates
back to just nineteen eighty-three so
you're a plant audience so you'll
appreciate this we knew about these in
plants a good 20 years before they
discovered him in their million cells so
once again plant biology is leading the
way so but this is was kind of a seminal
paper on the mammalian side where this
group was looking at receptor mediated
endocytosis of transferrin and recycling
of the transferrin receptor in during
red blood cell maturation and this is
simply using immuno gold to label
transferrin and showing that these
receptors which are normally on the
plasma membrane would become endocytosis
end up in these intraluminal vesicles
and then get dumped into the
extracellular space and at the time it
was thought of as a garbage
system so it didn't generate a lot of
excitement because who's interested in
garbage
and so these discovery of extracellular
vesicles basically just kind of was
ignored for about twenty years mostly
because it was just considered a waste
system that all changed though in 2007
so now this is just eleven years ago
where this paper was published in nature
cell biology that demonstrated that x's
immediate transfer of messenger rnas and
especially micro rna's allowed exchange
of genetic information between cells so
suddenly this seemed to be a mechanism
for intercellular communication for
transferring micro rnas and so that kind
of set off a huge renaissance in the
study of extracellular vesicles so the
mixed paper here in 2008 again nature
cell biology this is interesting when
glioblastoma so brain cancer
microvesicles transport RNA and proteins
that promote tumor growth and provide
diagnostic biomarkers and so that's been
a really big deal for the biotech
industry because the idea is that you
can simply purify vesicles from your
serum or even your urine see what RNAs
and proteins are there and then be able
to say whether you've got cancer or not
and so it turns out that when we pee
there's lots of vesicles in our urine
and there are companies that have
already been set up but basically are
trying to develop a rapid urine based
bio test for cancer but they're also
involved in the immune system so this is
a relevant paper to our topic
unidirectional transfer of micro RNA
loaded exosomes from t-cells the antigen
presenting cells so it's probably a
critical component of our innate immune
system works viruses have learned to
co-opt the exosome system and so they
can make their own viral micro rna's so
it's like herpes virus and
they're showing functional delivery of
viral microRNAs yet exosomes also
involved in tumor metastasis
so exosomes released by melanoma cells
prepare sentinel lymph nodes per tumor
metastasis so the idea is before the
tumor cell moves it's releasing these
exosomes
they spread out to the body suppress
immune responses that might otherwise
control the moving cancer cell and then
allow colonization of distant tissue
awesome brain development so regulation
of post synaptic retrograde signaling by
presynaptic exosome release and this is
actually done in drosophila this one so
it's not just mammalian cells brain
immune system interactions so why do you
feel so crappy when you have a cold and
your thoughts are muddled well maybe all
needed by exosomes so extra cellar
vesicle mediated transfer of genetic
information between the hematopoietic
system and the brain in response to
inflammation so this is one of the few
known mechanisms for transferring
genetic information across the
blood-brain barrier our disease secreted
micro RNA suppress a thorough genesis
behavior this is I think a really
interesting paper BMP regulated exosomes
from Drosophila male reproductive plants
reprogrammed female behavior so it turns
out that when fruit flies mate the
female does not want to mate again for
several days that behavior change and
not wanting to mate is dependent on
exosomes delivered by the male so that's
another fascinating aspect of exosomes
and probably the most relevant to this
talk is this paper from 2014 where
they're working on nematodes in mice and
it showed that exosome secreted by
nematode parasites transfer small rnas
to mammalian cells and modulate the
innate immunity and this is actually an
observation has been known for a long
time that people infected with nematodes
don't tend to have problems with asthma
there's immune system is suppressed
well it's probably mediated by micro
rna's that are being produced by the
nematodes so this is actually
fascinating okay so what's the evidence
that there may be RNA transfer by
extracellular vesicles and plants it
comes from this paper from Eileen Jin's
lab UC Riverside in 2013 I imagine many
of you saw this paper
she showed that botrytis produces small
rnas that can suppress plant immunity
and so what they did in that paper they
weren't looking at vesicles specifically
but they were able to I do
immunoprecipitate plants Argonaut
proteins and show that they were bound
to botrytis small rnas and that those
small rnas actually targeted plant genes
so the conclusion from this science
paper was that botrytis fungus is
producing small rnas that somehow get
across but try this plasma membrane
across the plant plasma membrane and
then interact with RNA I system in the
plant cell and so for us this was a
smoking gun to suggest that tetra-cell
or vesicles might be meeting and
transfer small RNAs from a fungus to a
plant we're interested in whether it
might work in the other direction as
well so Eileen followed up on this paper
I guess two years ago in 2016 with this
paper showing bi-directional across
kingdom RNA I and fungal uptake of
external RNAs confer plant protection
that was in nature plants and there she
actually could use naked RNAi apply that
to botrytis and show that you could
silence botrytis genes just with naked
RNA so botrytis has some ability to take
up RNA from the environment but it had
been known before this work even that
you can express double-stranded RNA in a
plant that silence is a fungal gene and
it can work quite well it's called host
induced gene silencing which again
raised the question how do those rnas
get out of the plant into the fungal
cell
and then lastly and I think most
relevant to this talk on this paper also
in 2016
showing that cotton plants can expert
micro rna's to inhibit virulence gene
expression in a fungal pathogen this was
actually in cotton and British psyllium
and there what this showed was that if
you identified these potential targets
in the fungus of the plant micro RNA
mutate that target so it's no longer a
base pair match to the plant micro RNA
you then made the fungus more virulence
and so that was pretty compelling
evidence that these micro rna's really
were targeting a fungal gene okay so
what we actually done so what we've
succeeded in doing is purifying the
extracellular vesicles and figuring out
what's inside of them and so the person
that did that is my grad student Brian
and this was his side project for the
first year and then turned into his
full-time project once they actually
figured out how to do it and so this is
his protocol and if you're interested in
doing this yourself brian is put
together a really detailed protocol in
bio protocol complete with a video but
anyway it's relatively straightforward
you simply submerge your leaves or roots
it works or roots to in a buffer apply a
vacuum so suck out all the air from your
tissue release the vacuum it sucks the
buffer into the leaf you then do a low
speed centrifugation that gently
squeezes the leaves so you can recollect
the fluid so that's just interesting
later wash fluid or April plastic fluid
we filter that to filter out any like
broken trichomes or whatever do a
relatively low speed spin at ten
thousand times g to again pellet any
particles and then the key spin turns
out to be at forty thousand times g
that's fast enough that pellet vesicles
and then we're curious to see what was
left after that forty thousand times
she's spending a hundred thousand times
g and it turns out there's a lot of
stuff that comes down at a hundred
thousand times g and so it's important
not to go straight to a hundred thousand
and the reason i mention that is if you
read them
in literature that standard leaves
what's done they do a low-speed spin at
ten thousand and then they spin at a
hundred thousand if you do that with
plant material you'll get a lot of stuff
that you don't want but to really clean
it up we take the pellet from forty
thousand times G and run it on a density
gradient so this if you look at the
pellet from your forty thousand times G
spin by transmission electron microscopy
so this is just negative stain you see
these structures that look like beanbag
chairs and that's essentially what they
are because you're you're putting these
grids into a vacuum the electron
microscope they collapse and the stain
sort of accumulates where it's collapsed
but this size range here is around 50 to
200 nanometers p100 fraction has all
this much smaller material and if you do
dynamic light scattering you can see the
p40 fraction averages around 120
nanometers whereas P 100 fraction is
down more around 15 to 20 nanometers I'm
so very different size particles but all
of our activity is in this P 40 fraction
where the best skills are and so we we
were confident that the p40 fraction was
what we wanted when we did this
experiment where we isolated that P for
diffraction from transgenic plants they
had GFP fusions to this pen one protein
in the pen three protein so I mentioned
earlier in the talk that Paul Scholten
Leafers lab had isolated these plant
mutants that had enhanced penetration by
powdery barley powdery mildew on
Arabidopsis plants so he cloned these
pen mutant genes one of them was pen one
and that turned out to encode one of
these syntax ins so the proteins
involved in membrane fusion and three is
an ABC transporter protein they had
shown both of these accumulate in
papillae so they seemed to accumulate
outside the plant cell so porosity
seemed like good potential biomarkers
for extracellular vesicles and so what's
shown here is the p40 fraction from the
pen one gfp plant by confocal microscopy
I mean it looked like a starry night and
so that was really exciting for us
because that really indicated that these
vesicles were carrying pen one and pen
three and so consistent with our
predictions so we wanted to see whether
the pen one was really inside the
vesicles which is what we would predict
based on the topology of how these
extrasolar vesicles are thought to be
produced and so did I say whether
they're actually inside versus outside
we did a protease protection assay so if
you just incubate the vesicles with
trypsin you do not see any degradation
of the pen one gfp fusion protein if you
soluble eyes the vesicles of Triton and
entry the trypsin you completely be
grayed so that simply told us that the
pin1 protein is actually inside the
vesicles not stuck to the outside to
prove to us and our reviewers that we
were not just getting contaminated
vesicles from inside plant cells we
looked at a series of transgenic
Arabidopsis plants tagged with different
yfp gfp fusion proteins that marked
different vesicles so this is a marker
for Golgi this is a marker for plasma
membranes this is a marker for late
endosomes and this is a marker for early
endosomes and so if you look at the
total lysate our antibodies detecting
all of those proteins you look at the
p40 fraction the only thing that comes
out is the pen one protein so these
other common endo membrane marker
proteins are not there so this was
demonstrated that we would do not have a
lot of contamination from vesicles from
inside the plant cell we also asked the
question would induction of defense
responses increased vesicle recovery
from our April plastic fluid and the
answer was yes so here we use salicylic
acid to treat the plants and then we
from the same amount of plant material
we isolated mythical x' and then just at
a Western blot and you can see a lot
more of GFP pen one is what we're
looking at here
from si treated leaves versus non si
treated leaves and then as a second
marker we use their protein that we had
identified by mass spec as being present
in the vesicles called Patel and one and
that also we could see a lot more Patel
in one in our p40 pellet from sa treated
leaves and this is very reproducible we
always get at least twice sometimes
three times as many vesicles from plants
that have been treated with sa versus
untreated okay but what we really wanted
to do was to do mass spec on the
vesicles and RNA see on the vesicles and
so before doing that we decided to take
the extra effort of really cleaning them
up by using a density gradient and so
what's shown here is a fraction from AIA
Dixon all gradient and here's the
density of each fraction and this is
again GFP pen one as a marker and we can
see that this kind of one peak across
the gradient where the GFP pen one shows
up so we pull these three fractions and
then look at them first by confocal so
this is just a black-and-white image of
the confocal you can see the high
concentration of vesicles in these
fractions this is what it looks like by
negative stain and this is what it looks
like by cry OEM and I don't know if you
can see it but the you can actually see
a lipid bilayer when you look at this
vesicle down here so this is just
convincing ourselves that these really
are vesicles and so it was again from
this pulled fraction that we went ahead
and did mass spec analysis and so when
we do that what we see is a really
interesting collection of proteins and
it's unlike any other proteome that's
been published as far as its mixture of
proteins that are present so first of
all there are proteins that we'd expect
to be associated with vesicles because
these are all social trafficking so Rab
gtp aces regulate and no membrane
trafficking Tetris bannon's are well
known proteins from the mammalian
exosome world syntax ins I've already
been talking about and one of course was
the marker next sentence is another
common class
Sabino membrane trafficking proteins
that we found and then of interest to
the Pseudomonas people here
we also found rin for rin for sensor RPM
one interacting protein for it's a
really intensely studied protein that as
a target of several different effector
proteins from Pseudomonas and it seems
to be involved in regulating secretion
of Kalos among other activities and so
it was intriguing to us that it was it
was in these extra cellar vesicles but
also there were a number of transporter
proteins including glucosinolate
transporters which is interesting so
rabid abscess glucosinolates are
important antimicrobial compounds that
brassicas produce there's also
aquaporins and proton pumps actually
macular ATP ASE's suggesting that these
vessels may have some ability to
regulate their pH also stress response
proteins lrr protein kinases murasa
Nace's is quite interesting Raza noises
are enzymes that break down glucose
analytes to release isothiocyanates so
the fact that we have both glucosinolate
transporters and murasa mazes would
suggest that you might be able to
produce these isothiocyanates and one
idea we have is that these might be
packaged into separate vesicles because
you probably wouldn't want to put them
in the same vesicle because then you'd
be releasing these highly toxic
compounds and you probably don't want to
do that unless you're inside an insect
and you want to kill that insect one
important point about the proteome is
that we calculated 84 percent of the
proteins we identified lacked a signal
peptide so these are proteins are by
definition in April Plast but they're
getting out of the cell through
non-conventional protein secretion and
that makes sense that they're getting
packaged inside vesicles inside the cell
so that again suggests that the way
proteins get loaded into these vesicles
probably bypasses the standard ER or
signal peptide directed pathway
okay so as I mentioned we can also do
this from roots and we've done in a lots
of different plant species now this one
simply shows that if we take soybean
roots we can isolate extra cellar
vesicles and we use antibody directly to
pen one we see abundant pen one in the
extracellular vesicles from soybean
roots and so this is making us think
that these vesicles may play a role in
regulating interactions in the root
microbiome so that soil interface at
roots are secreting vesicles into that
space that may have a lot play a role in
communication between microbes in the
soil and the roots okay so one of our
real foci over the last 12 months has
been trying to figure out what sort of
RNA these vesicles carry and our first
evidence that they actually did contain
RNA came from this experiment here where
we're using a dye that was actually
developed in the mammalian exposome
world to sustain RNA so it's called EXO
red and so we just stain our p 4d palate
with EXO red we see abundant staining
and we use vesicles that are from a gfp
pen one plant we see all the green and
what's interesting is there's a high
degree of overlap but not a hundred
percent and so these three dots here are
white because they show up with EXO red
and they show up with gfp pen one but
this dot does not show up with gfp pen
one it shows up only with the RNA stain
and so this is some evidence that these
vesicles are in fact heterogeneous so
they don't all contain exactly the same
proteins and RNA in fact they're not big
enough that do that even and so we
expect to see heterogeneity
but this is a nice evidence of that so
we've done RNA seek and we're learning
some very interesting things turn the
lights up before you all go to sleep
so the
first thing we've learned and it was
kind of surprising to us is that the
vesicles are highly enriched in what we
are calling tiny RNAs
so small are in a world most people talk
about micro RNAs that are 21 nucleotides
long
and si RNAs are 22 to 24 nucleotides
long we see those but we see a large
number of 12 nucleotide 13 nucleotide 14
nucleotide 11 nucleotide and so just to
explain the graph here the green bars is
the RNA seek data from the extracellular
vesicles the blue bars is RNA that we
find left over in the supernatant after
we spin down that p40 pellet and so
there seems to be RNA in extracellular
space that doesn't pellet at 40,000
times G so it may just be soluble RNA
that's out there and how that's getting
out there is an interesting question and
then total RNA is just the small RNA
that you get when you grind up a whole
leaf and so this is typically the
pattern when you just grind up a whole
leaf you know 90% of your RNA secrets
are in that 18 and larger size range and
same for the supernatant
but that's certainly not true for the
Eevee's so v's are preferentially
packaging these smaller rnas so what are
they targeting well no we expected to
see lots of micro rna's and and when we
do we we see plenty of micro RNA but as
a total fraction of what's in the
vesicles it's dwarfed by the SI RNAs
that target transpose ax balem it's so
that these are reads that map to
transpose element sequences these are
reads that map to see DNA's this is some
ribosomal RNA and trna gets mapped to
precursors refers to micro RNA
precursors I think this is quite
interesting the V's are highly enriched
or the loop that's formed during
processing of micro RNA so when you make
a micro RNA you know it's transcribed by
polymerase 2
so long precursor it folds up into a
stem-loop structure and the micro RNA
gets cut out of that stem-loop structure
well these RNAs are in the vesicles
preferentially contain the loop from the
stem loop structure we don't know what
that means yet but we think it might be
important this could be taking out the
trash but it may also have a function
and that's what we're trying to sort out
now so I said there are micro rna's and
when we look at what the most abundant
ones are they actually differ somewhat
from what the most abundant ones are and
the leaf overall and so this is the list
of our top six based on counts and I've
put asterisk by ones that are
particularly interesting and so MRI 162
was in the news last summer when it was
shown that it's particularly abundant in
bee bread so bee bread is concentrated
pollen that bees collect and feed their
larvae and the reason that was in the
news is this paper here in PLoS genetics
showed that MRI 162 can suppress Queen
development and honey bees so in other
words it's important for maintaining
worker status in a honey bee hive and
it's being regulated by this plant micro
RNA so perhaps pollen is particularly
rich in MRI 162 and maybe it's being
packaged into vesicles that can be
easily taken up by the Queen's I mean by
the larvae MRI 159 and 166 those are the
RNA micro RNAs I talked about beginning
of the talk that seemed to target genes
in verticillium dally I in cotton so it
was the putative targets of these two
micro rnas that when they mutated in
verticillium may the verticillium more
resistant so it's striking that these
happen to be the most abundant ones and
our EBS and then MRI 161 that's a
notable micro RNA because it induces
production of so-called Phase II RNA so
these are si RNAs that are produced in a
phase phased pattern from an individual
messenger RNA
and it's been shown in when bomas grew
that those actually target specific
genes in my father and Almighty pathogen
so these are just to suggest that these
microRNAs may well have a function in
the ABS so are they taken up by the
fungus and so here's a really nice
experiment that Brian did in which he
simply inoculated transgenic plants
expressing pen 3 fused with Gus so pen 3
is the possum ABC transporter with
multiple transmembrane domains fused to
beta glucuronidase which you can detect
using a colorless thigh that turns blue
in response to the beta glucuronidase so
if you this is called dr. comb growing
on an Arabidopsis leaf wild-type leaf
there's no background activity of beta
glucuronidase that's one of the reasons
it's such a great marker for plants and
you can see accumulation I think here a
blue dye in the spores of the contactor
comb that's germinated on this
transgenic Arabidopsis plant and the
fact that the Gus here is fused to this
ABC transporter strongly suggests that
the fungus is taking up this plasma
membrane protein EB protein from the
host plant you can also do the same
experiment of powdery mildew and again
you see uptake of the gus activity by
the fungus so it really suggests that
these eb proteins are getting into the
fungi when the fungi feed on the plant
this is simply close up of that last
image of the powdery mildew spore and
again you can see it throughout the
hyphy so brian then took this call talk
to come and simply germinated it on
glass slides and added v's directly to
the fungus so these are purified
vesicles
from a pen three gust plant and again
you can see the blue staining when
they're germinated in the presence of
the Eevee's and of course no blue
staining at all when you germinate it
just in the buffer alone without the
eby's there so it looks like the spores
take up these vesicles quite quickly
this is 24 hours after applying the
vesicles
and so the next question that Brian
wanted to address is do they move
systemically in a plan and to address
that he did graphs with a rabbit ops
Asst and this is not an easy thing to do
because a rabbit ops Asst stems are
really small and so you can't do this
after you've had too much coffee but the
way this does this experiment as he
takes transgenic pen 3 Gus seedlings and
grass shoots to a non-transgenic route
or vice versa transgenic ruth to a
non-transgenic chute and this looks for
a movement of the gus activity across
the graph junction and so when you do
that you clearly see movement so this is
wild touch chute grafted on to the
transgenic route here's the graph
junction and you can see this blue color
moving up into the apical meristem
region of the chute and I'll focus in on
this in a moment because it was a really
interesting pattern up there and it goes
both directions so you take transgenic
chute grafted onto a root and you can
see this root is becoming heavily
stained and it's moving along direction
and this is about three weeks after
setting up the graft do this with
control plants and there's no background
at all so that's can really nice this
guess marker that way if you zoom in
then on these graphs so this is the non
transgenic shoot what you see is that
Gus activities accumulating and these
newly emerging leaves and especially in
the trichomes
so these pokey things those are the
trichomes on these newly emerging leaves
you can also see suddenly Gus activity
here in the petioles of these older
leaves but that was really interesting
to us that the gus activity seems to be
preferentially accumulating the
trichomes and trichomes are defensive
structures and one of our hypotheses is
is that these eby's actually serve to
transport glucose in elates because they
have a solute assimilate transporters in
them and perhaps this is a mechanism for
accumulating glucosinolates into
trichomes they also
this is now the non-transgenic roots
grafted to the transgenic shoots you can
see it accumulate in root hairs which is
one of the reasons I think they may well
be involved in communication with the
like the root of microbiome and then as
a negative control what we're currently
using now is a fusion between the jazz
one protein and beta glucuronidase so
jazz one is a regulator of jazz monarch
acid singling regulates pictu activity
and importantly it mostly accumulates in
the nuclei we have no evidence that ever
gets into extracellular vesicles so it
shouldn't move via extracellular
vesicles and when we do graphs with that
we see absolutely zero accumulation in
trichomes so this really seems to be
dependent on fusion to this pen 3 probe
so it kind of lastly whether I want to
finish up with is one of the reasons we
set up this whole system is so we could
do genetics with a rabid abscess so we
are now screening through mutants
looking for mutants that are defective
in either Eevee production or in loading
of proteins or RNA into extracellular
vesicles and this is one of our first
kind of positive results and this is
what this shows is that we take a double
mutant in pen one and sip 122 these are
homologous snare proteins what we see is
that they're defective in loading this
patel and protein into the vesicles i'm
not showing you the data but this
mutinous produces the same number of
vesicles as a wild-type plant but it
seems to be defective and produced in
loading in this patel and protein we
need to do mass spec on this to figure
out what else is missing but we know for
sure this protein is missing you'll
notice the said 2 mutation is here the
only reason that is there is it turns
out if you mutate both of these syntax
ins you turn on sa biosynthesis and you
get a stunted plant and to avoid the
stunting we needed to down regulate the
sa biosynthesis and so we had to add the
said 2 mutation but anyway this kind of
gives you an idea of our approach to
start trying to dissect genetically what
required to produce TVs somewhat to our
surprise so far we we've tested probably
15 different mutants that are known to
be defective in different aspects of
endo membrane trafficking this double
mutant is the only thing where we've
seen in effect so far and we haven't
found a single mutant yet that affects
the number of vesicles that are produced
okay so kind of major questions that
this work generates are here so these
multi basic your bodies are destined for
plasma membrane fusion do they
fundamentally differ from those that are
destined for lysosome and Bakula fusion
so for those of you that know a little
bit of cell biology multi basic their
bodies have classically been studied as
vehicles for transporting plasma
membrane receptors to the central
vacuole for degradation we think that
those multi particular bodies are
probably an independent pathway from the
multiply Pacific bodies that go out but
that's not a generally accepted feeling
in the mammalian world but the reason I
believe that's the case least implant
systems is that by EEM the multi
particular body is like very different
and so if that's the case we need to
figure out really what is the pathway
that gives rise to these MB B's if it's
completely different from the pathway
that classic MB B's involved so how are
proteins targeted for import into e B's
our escort proteins involved our
autophagy genes involved we really don't
know yet
certainly some taxons are involved based
on that one result I showed you how are
these small RNAs especially the tiny
rnase how are they targeted to e B's and
how are they distinguished such a only a
subset of cellular small RNAs or
packaged in two V's I didn't show you
the data but some micro RNAs are highly
enriched in V's relative to the whole
leaf how are they targeted to specific
recipient cells such as trichomes I
can't think of a mechanism for that it's
gonna be really interesting to try to
figure that out
are they taken up by fungal cells and
plant cells we know they're taking up
quickly by these germinating spores how
does that mediate it are there specific
surface proteins required for that do
they media transfer of s RNAs and
proteins into plants based on the gas
they certainly media transport of
proteins we need to actually do some
tests with specific s RNAs to see if we
can silence specific genes do they
mediate intracellular signalling during
the fence I suspect that they do but we
don't have any evidence for that yet do
they mean into the immediate intranets
intercellular signaling during
development if they're moving great
distances they probably probably are and
lastly since this is right before lunch
I'll leave you with this thought do they
mediate transfer s RNAs into humans and
this isn't just a joke there's actually
a very active field looking at s plant s
RNAs in our serum so you eat a bunch of
broccoli in about an hour you will see
broccoli s RNAs in your serum how do
they get there how do they survive your
digestive system there's pretty good
evidence as probably that sits inside
vesicles what does it mean there's some
a couple experiments done in mice
suggesting that actually can influence
gene expression in mice at least when
you introduce these vesicles that carry
si RNAs okay so this final thanks a lot
of that si RNA analysis we are doing in
collaboration with blake myers at the
donald davenport center and particularly
patricia Baldrige has really helped out
with the tiny RNA analysis unfertile
Kristensen has been sending us some of
his mutants which has been very useful
and they are now starting to look at
eby's in their lab and it has some
really interesting new data suggesting
that there's two distinct classes that
we use based on density if you do the
density gradient correctly Richard
O'Connell I showed you that the
beautiful high pressure freezing image
I'm he's helping us out what they call
talked to come
and then Josh Blakesley I didn't get a
chance to talk about what he's doing but
he is metabolomic expert and he has been
doing some analyses so look for
glucosinolates and other compounds in
the EBS and I'll stop there and yeah so
so the rudy be the only ones we've
looked at so far from soybean and and
we've compared the leaf soybean abies to
the root soybean TVs and they looked
quite similar the soybean eby's
definitely differ from their rabid ops
ECB's for example there's no
glucosinolate transporters in soybean
there were a lot more lipoxygenase --iz
in the soybean v's than we saw in the
rabbit opposite CDs which could be
interesting but yeah we did not see a
big difference from root to leaf and
that one data set yeah absolutely and
it's just mentioned the very end that we
are eagerly eagerly awaiting data from
Josh because that's that's his expertise
and he's particularly interested in
hormone signaling and he's confident
that they carry oxen so they could be
involved in systemic oxen transport he's
also going to be looking at the lipid
profiles of the eby's he's got hints
that there are indeed glucosinolates
there but it needs to do a couple more
repeats before we can really start
showing the data but yeah definitely
very interested in the panel
the relief decide about the so so what
we know about that simply is that when
we look at the proteome content of the
Eevee's and compared to proteomes that
have published from other cellular
compartments the most similar proteome
that we could find in the literature was
so-called detergent-resistant micro
domains which is a controversial concept
but basically if you purify plasma
membranes and then treat them with a
detergent and then pellet that's what's
left over so it's the stuff that is
resistant to detergent whether those
represent contiguous functional domains
is debated but whatever it is that
renders those plasma membrane regions
resistant detergent those proteins are
highly similar to what we see in the
extracellular vesicles which would be
yeah we don't really have a measurement
of that yet because said these graphs
are just technically challenging to do
so he's only looked at three weeks he
hasn't looked at a week in two weeks in
three weeks but that's on our list of
experiments to do but clearly it's
traveled a long ways by three weeks so I
would guess it's probably you know the
seedlings are tiny when you do the graft
and so I would suspect after a day
they've already moved across and spread
but that's just speculation the Eevee's
get out my cell wall do you have any
feeling for what percentage but the
totally beads that are available are
within the tissue or pharmacist in April
class flushing
and the third is it be considered using
like protoplasm but several there any
enzyme to release right so so we really
have no good measurement of what
fraction of the EVs we're getting
through our cell wall washing procedure
we haven't like gone back and done a.m.
on the vacuum infiltrated leaves what
you could probably do but you've not
done that site I can't really answer
that question my intuition is we're
probably not getting a large percent how
they get to the cell wall I mean so
while it's a complex mesh and it's
probably not uniform pore size and so I
suspect that they they just wiggle
through the evidence to support that
there's actually a pretty recent paper
with the fungal cell wall showing that
the they were using some sort of marker
protein and just showing that mark these
marker protein when it was put in to
sense the artificial vesicles could
easily be crossing the fungal cell wall
and getting into the fungus where nobody
expected it could so there was something
about just being in a vesicle that
allowed uptake by the fungus quite
rapidly and so I imagine the same thing
could be happening with the plant cell
so we don't understand the physics of
that protoplast stain we've talked about
it but we haven't actually done it the
one thing that we have done is fiddled
with the pH of the extraction buffer and
it does so we'd standardly use I think
it's pH six because we were just trying
to be as gentle as possible to the April
Plast and not cause any sort of
artificial things but Brian did do a pH
for extraction once and his sense was
they got about twice as many vesicles
out so it may help to loosen up the cell
wall
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu